hi guys Samuel Leeds here and today I
wanted to just give a little bit of
information on lease option agreement
and the paper that you should be using
and a little bit about the structure of
them and how they work and that kind of
stuff so if you're actively looking for
lease option agreements or if you're
interested in the whole idea of buying
properties without using any money then
this video might be really helpful for
you so first thing is what is a lease
option agreement and do they really work
yes absolutely
I built up quite a lot of my property
portfolio through lease option
agreements and just in the last three
weeks I've secured three the lease
option agreement deals so at least
option agreements absolutely are
fantastic in fact the ideal what I did
at lease option agreement deal that I
did back in 2012 and now it's 2017 in
five years time I secured it there with
no money down every single month I've
been making a profit of 350 pounds a
month which isn't amazing but it's not
bad considering I didn't put anything
down to start with a bot from about a
thousand pound legal fees so friend of
McDonagh month but actually over five
years by the cumulative a capital
appreciation of fifty five thousand
pounds so that's over ten thousand
pounds a year pause the rental income
and I didn't put anything down for it at
all so that was a fantastic deal what I
want to talk to you today today about is
the paper you should be using I mean I
need people that have come onto my
property investors crash course they
learn about how to do lease option
agreements they go crazy they secured
some lease option agreements and they
effectively take over the mortgage and
they're making money every single month
and that's great but they haven't had
the felicity
draw up the paperwork properly which is
gonna be a problem you don't have to do
all the Facebook the popular you can
take it on and you can make money from
it and that's fantastic
however after three five seven years
whenever you come to buy the property if
you haven't had the seller be legally
represented by a solicitor and had a
bespoke contract drawn up a lease option
agreement professionally drawn up if you
haven't done that when you come to buy
the property at the end of the term it
will have probably gone up considerably
in value because property prices rise
over time and if the seller says hey I
don't want us to have to do now I want
to sell with an estate agent and make an
extra twenty fifty hundred thousand
pounds you've effectively lost out on
tens of thousands of pounds just for the
sake of a few hundred pounds of Jamie
drawn up properly so I would really
really encourage you guys to get the
lease option agreement drawn up properly
gate solicitor at least to represent the
seller but I would personally say guess
solicited to represent the seller and
guess solicitor to also we represent you
as well super duper important now the
sisters that I use I think if I said
publicly to everybody who I use they
would be absolutely bombarded with phone
calls so what I would say instead is
come on to my property investors crash
course if you then can go and secure and
don't money down deal and you need
someone to draw the paperwork up and
then get in touch with me and and when
you've actually got a deal on the table
you know what of course I'll help you
hours but I don't just want everyone to
go crazy ringing up the solicitors and
picking up picking their brains
and actually loads of questions and
questions because that would be unfair
then hit your property for a lease
option agreement it's really really
simple anybody that is selling their
house that doesn't need the money now
used to buy on a lease option agreement
because you can say I'll buy it you
don't need the money now so I'll pay you
in five years time and then in the
meantime you're paid of a mostly beat or
cover their mortgage payments and you
will start gaining from a monthly cash
flow passive income and you'll be able
to gain from all chance appreciation
available well they've got what they
wanted to they've got rid of the
property you've got a property to bridge
it really is easy up to three in the
last three weeks many of my students and
partners do these types of deals all the
time and that is just fantastic so I
would say if you're not doing lease
option agreements study them to learn
how to do them read my book column to
the crash course figuring out and secure
some but make sure that you get the
paperwork drawn up properly god bless
you and that's all for now